I'm a nerd web and in addition to my
other responsibilities I have created an
early stage investments network called
the web investment Network many of you
have set your ideas for us to look at
today we are going to vet those
presentations typically we see anywhere
from fifteen or thirty companies per
week the first thing that we look for is
industry focus
what was the most creative whether it
was in our sweet spot or the one that
was monitoring for pollution in China I
think it's a very big problem how
confident are you that they can actually
pull it off it looks like their product
is still in the design stage but it
looked promising
and they pitched a Mark Cuban already
it's unclear
they said they have a quote here from
him saying it could be interesting
startup experience as a Rainmaker
battle and they're our young team so
it's really hard to evaluate so in those
cases we tend to lean on product is
evidence capability there was an app did
you try to download it play with it I
had trouble finding them in the App
Store okay I like that last one it
always seems impossible until it's done